hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my interview with my favorite author of
all time the best-selling fantasy book
author brandon sanderson and in this
clip we are talking about the idea of
how do we figure out what to do with our
lives now this is a clip from a bonus
episode of the deep dive podcast link to
the full episode down in the video
description but yeah i hope you enjoy
this clip so it's as part of this
equation of help helping us figure out
what to do with our lives
but anyway it it it seems like there's
broadly like two strands of it there's
one strand which is a
find find something that you enjoy and
do it and then there's another strand
which is like find enjoyment in the
things that you're doing
and it sounds like for you writing
writing was that thing of you found
something you were passionate about and
you found that you that you enjoyed it
as well
do you have any thoughts or advice for
people who are in that position where
they're like i'm not really sure what
i'm passionate about like how do you
think about that
yeah it is hard in some ways because
i've noticed this in some of my friends
some of my roommates in college and
things like this where i had this
all-consuming passion and i was going
for bro if i didn't end up selling my
fallback jobs were were not the same
sort of caliber right it's i end up
becoming an insurance salesman or
something i i couldn't really have even
become a professor because becoming at
least in the states an english professor
requires certain hoops to jump through
were phds and things that i just was not
doing in grad school i wasn't working on
the papers in the journals and all this
stuff and so i was all in
on this and i had a roommate who
at one point told me brandon not all of
us are like that i
i do not have an all-consuming passion i
want to find a job i want to enjoy it
and i want to come home and play video
games and that is still how he is he's
in my writing group and i
basically i was myopic early before in
my pre-published years because i had
this everyone must have this
all-consuming passion sort of thing
which i just don't think is true i think
there are a lot of very fulfilling jobs
out there and in fact one of the things
that i often say to people is if you are
a writer do you really like writing
programming and writing
feel very similar in fact i had to stop
taking i took a programming class in
college and after it i'm like i can
never take another one of these because
that semester was the hardest i ever had
writing because i would do my homework
and then i'd feel like i'd already
written for the day when i'd been coding
and it would leave me kind of mentally
exhausted and most of my other classes
use a different part of my brain coding
is basically writing it's the same sort
of thing when you're writing a novel you
are problem solving how to achieve these
things you want to these results you
want to get out and the output is reader
investment and emotion rather than the
outputs that you might have for the
object you're coding or something like
this but i think that you can um humans
are they're things that drive us one is
creativity being able to make something
but another is serving people i had a
lot of fun working a graveyard shift at
the hotel being able to be the person
that at night when somebody needed
something at the hotel i just got it for
them i made them happy i didn't have to
sell a single thing because no one was
coming in and buying rooms i was just
there to make their experience better
and i found that wildly fulfilling
shockingly fulfilling for me now of
course i was writing at the same time
i'm at the front desk typing away
interrupted to go get somebody something
they need and so it was okay was a good
match of the two things but i think that
we acknowledging what it is that that
human beings generally find fulfilling
finding out what it is you find
fulfilling is it finding a need and
fulfilling it is it being able to be
creative is it problem solving you can
find these general groupings of things
that you happen to find satisfying
fulfilling and you can then find a whole
bunch of different careers and things
that that target in that that that
grouping of yours and just like writing
computer programming you're very similar
there's a lot of things like that out
there and i often say try a bunch of
different things the way that we prepare
people for the workplace i wish it
involved a lot more variety i wish there
were more opportunities for us to try
different things out to try different
jobs out try different majors out and
really find what people find fulfilling
in them because if i hadn't had
this teacher get me into reading who
knows what would have happened with me
and i everyone thought i was a reluctant
reader that i didn't like reading when
the truth was i just had not found the
right books yet hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day